on se sens nauséeux on a le ventre
gonflé c'est une indigestion autrement
dit une digestion qui se passe mal mais
tout d'abord voyons comment se passe une
digestion normale
dans la digestion il ya plusieurs phases
la première phase c'est quand on a mal
les aliments il ya déjà là salif qui
commence avec les enzymes salivaire
avoir un effet sur les aliments ensuite
les aliments décembre dans par le
chauffage dans l'estomac l'estomac c'est
cette poche située à gauche de notre
abdomen
c'est là que les aliments sont broyés et
brasser grâce à des contractions
musculaires c'est une action mécanique
dans le même temps les molécules qui
composent ces aliments sont découpées
par une action chimique
les sucres et son gastrique avec les
enzymes gastrique ont commencé à couper
les grosses molécules pour que ce soit
plus digeste
l'estomac près par les aliments pour
leur passage dans les intestins c'est là
que les molécules découpé en nutriments
passe dans le sang pour être assimilée
l'estomac est donc au coeur du processus
de digestion mais que se passe-t-il si
nous mangeons trop pour le savoir nous
allons regarder ce que mac lesggy a dans
le ventre
direction l'hôpital d'antony en région
parisienne avec care ginier et valérie
laurent bonjour marc bonjour docteur
bonjour docteur j'aimerais comprendre
une chose pourquoi dès que je mange trop
je me sens ballonné parfois ça me
réveille la nuit c'est au niveau de
l'estomac probablement et donc pour le
voir on va faire un transit ah oui un
transit c'est à dire un examen de mon
transit c'est ça absolument
[Musique]
mac lesggy va passer une radio de
l'estomac il se positionne devant la
machine et il va boire ce liquide
étrange c'est de la baryte à minéral
très dense qui absorbe les rayons x et
devient alors visibles par contraste
voilà le petit déjeuner merci beaucoup
c'est lourd
et regardez on voit très nettement le
liquide remplir l'estomac de mac en
temps réel etonnant non
[Musique]
est ce que ça veut dire que l'estomac
c'est une grande boîte ville et ça va se
remplir ou est-ce que l'estomac se
dilate au fur et à mesure que j'avale
des boissons ou des aliments par
l'estomac c'est un sac qui est plus ou
moins remplies au départ le matin on a
digéré tout ce qu'on avait pris le soir
et on a essentiellement un peu d'air
dans l'estomac et le fait de le remplir
il va se déplier
elle va se décliner un peu comme une
chaussette
physiologiquement nous avons tous le
même estomac
lorsque nous sommes à jeun il est replié
sur lui-même et n'est pas très grand
environ 500 millilitres de contenance
soit à peine plus que la taille d'un
poing fermé lorsque l'on ingère un
liquide ou des aliments il se déplie peu
à peu et se dilate pour s'adapter à la
quantité qu'il reçoit tenez vous bien il
peut contenir jusqu'à quatre litres et
devenir huit fois plus gros corpo
mais attention la nourriture est
toujours évacuée vers l'intestin par un
orifice dont le diamètre lui ne varie
pas en fait à la sortie de l'estomac il
ya un
une petite valve qui s'appelle le pilote
qui va libérer petit à petit
bol alimentaire digéré par coty volume
et uniquement lorsqu'il a une
consistance adapté à sa progression dans
la suite de l'intestin pour poursuivre
la division le problème c'est que c'est
l'estomac est trop rempli les deux
actions de la digestion mécanique et
chimique ce faux plus difficilement
dans un premier temps tout est vraiment
stockés dans l'estomac pour la digestion
et ça passe en fait en petites quantités
dans l'intestin tout à fait quand on
ingère un volume normal il ya un temps
de digestion où il y a une fonction de
digestion mais si on mange un repas qui
est trop important ou trop riches en
quelque sorte on dépasse les capacités
de fonctionnement de l'estomac et c'est
à ce moment là que les symptômes
apparaissent
l'évacuation par le pilote ne se fait
pas correctement on parle donc d'un
digestion les nausées sont provoquées
par la présence trop longue des aliments
dans l'estomac
la première cause d'indigestion et donc
la quantité mais elle est aussi aggravé
par la composition du repas une notion
de volume absorbé aussi de qualité si on
mange trop sucrés trop gras ça peut
contribuer à cette cette institution
quand on consomme en trop grande
quantité du sucre et surtout du gras on
va atteindre plus vite les limites de
l'estomac exactement les graisses ne
sont pas solubles dans l'eau par
conséquent les enzymes ne peuvent pas
facilement les décomposer leur digestion
ne va vraiment commencer que dans les
intestins
quant au sucre c'est le contraire très
facilement assimilé par les intestins
ils peuvent de ce fait dérégler le reste
de notre organisme s'ils sont consommés
en excès
donc en conclusion mon estomac est
normal tout à fait quand je suis balloni
c'est tout simplement parce que j'ai
trop manger exactement
nous l'avons vu l'estomac est l'organe
responsable de l'indigestion mais alors
pourquoi parlons nous aussi de crise de
foie
la crise de foie décrite
de façon courante n'est pas forcément
lié à un problème deux fois elle est
plutôt lié souvent un problème de
d'indigestion le foin situé à côté de
l'estomac participe aussi à la digestion
en sécrétant de la bile qui se déverse
dans l'intestin il aide l'organisme à
digérer les molécules de graisse dans le
processus de digestion il entre donc en
action après l'estomac
par conséquent contrairement à une idée
reçue ce n'est pas notre foi qui nous
fait souffrir mais bel et bien notre
estomac alors quand notre gourmandise
nous rend malade que faire
audrey bus taxis nutritionnistes nous
donne quelques petits trucs un petit
rond dans de l'eau ça peut faire du bien
à l'estomac parce que ça va stimuler la
création de la bile du coup les amis on
est vraiment inutile j'allais en plus
des lourdeurs l'indigestion peut aussi
provoquer des aigreurs d'estomac pour
les éviter le bicarbonate de sodium est
un bon allié
salle à absorber surtout l'acidité de
l'estomac et au niveau aigreur on va
sentir moins cette aigreur et d'acidité
au niveau de l'estomac mais l'idéal
c'est quand même d' éviter l'indigestion
qu'on peut manger avant un repas de fête
par exemple on peut partir un jour des
choses assez légère on peut partir sur
des petites soupes des petits bouillons
des petites choses comme ça qu'ils vont
pouvoir déjà en fait un peu m l'estomac
un peu au repos à quelques jours d'un
grand repas on mange donc léger et
pendant
pendant un repas de fête vaut mieux
manger lentement et mâcher très
lentement justement pour faciliter le
travail de l'estomac et de bien des
poupées de bien mastiquer pour vraiment
bien broyer les aliments
en effet lorsque l'on mastic
correctement on commence déjà le travail
de l'estomac la digestion sera plus
rapide est bien plus facile
broyage des aliments augmentation de sa
taille vous savez maintenant que notre
estomac a des capacités étonnantes pour
s'adapter à nos appétits mais qu'il sait
aussi nous dire stop
[Musique]